- So, do you have any rituals before your
Don't, don't brag.
- That was my sexy leg,
by the way. (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Don't brag.
So wait, do you, do y'all
have any like rituals
that you do before, like?
- You know, just blasting
music, getting excited,
but also ice baths after the show.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Derek] Without a doubt.
- [Kelly] I wanna try this.
- [Derek] Let's do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, because people say-
- Let's go.
- it's really healthy.
So I have these baths set up for us.
Wouldn't that be amazing if we're like?
No, I do. I wanna do it
because I just watched
this whole thing on accident about it.
- [Derek] Yeah.
- And I was like,
"That's interesting."
And I don't have to, like
work out, you just sit in it.
I'm really into that.
Like, so I'm like, but it's
really healthy for you.
- Yeah, it's really great.
It's obviously for
inflammation, just recovery,
you know, but also it's just good
for like stress and-
- Circulation.
All the things.
- [Derek] Circulation,
all those things.
- Yeah.
- But that's definitely a big ritual.
Listening to music, getting pumped up
and I do have like an incantation,
like I say something right
before I go on stage.
I won't share it with you guys.
- I know that's your own to have,
but is it like a superstitious thing?
'Cause I have something similar.
- It's not so much superstitious,
it's more of just like something
where I demand something for myself.
It's like, I'm not like,
- Yeah.
- "I hope it goes well tonight".
I'm like, it's like a,
"This is something like
I'm going out there, I'm
gonna serve this audience.
I'm gonna give them everything
I absolutely have every night".
So there's no question that I'm gonna
put on the best show
possible every single night.
There's no question.
- I love how different we are.
We're gonna have to bleep this,
but I literally just say to my band,
"Hope we don't (beep) up."
(everyone laughing)
Like that's, that's literally what I say.